foreign
[Music]
that is what the preachers cry from the
spiers of their temples
what commanders tell the soldiers in
their service
The indominus Crusade meets with Triumph
after Triumph
day by day we tear Imperium nihilus from
the spoilers grip and though we are the
set on all sides
with each battle we drive back the
mutant
the heretic
the alien
as I speak these words our forces Engage
The remnants of Leviathan
foreign
lost worlds atoning for old Shades a
crusade to cleanse the Stars
taking the fight to the enemy
foreign
exit bar we broke their High Fleet
soon their foulness will be but a memory
that is what the preachers say
relief will not save us
[Music]
lies will not protect us
but it is our hope
that will damn us
foreign
[Music]
s
Victory as the Imperium rots around us
Victory as Humanity rages against the
dying of the light
foreign
[Music]
victory
hello everyone I'm Rahul Kohli and
welcome to the 2023 Warhammer skull
showcase skulls is the annual
celebration of Warhammer video games
we're going to kick off the next week of
promotions with a look at some of the
exciting new titles and updates coming
to Warhammer setting including bolt gun
where I voice the part of stern Guard
veteran malam kaido of the ultramarines
so get comfortable and prepare to enjoy
some of the awesome new trailers and
exclusive reveals coming soon
thank you
foreign
[Music]
in the tales of the Norse and the kurgan
there is Legend of a warrior
unparalleled
champion
forged in the heart of fear
who reached into the grave and found
only hate
oh
foreign
[Music]
to embrace such hate is to become a
nightmare
it is to wield dread as lesser men
wheeled armies
it is to become fear itself
[Music]
it is to become the hammer storm
foreign
[Music]
thank you
all right
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
you're very good
[Music]
foreign
hello everyone I'm Rahul Kohli and as
you all now know the voice of malam
kaido the battle hard and Stern Guard
veteran on a perilous mission to destroy
chaos Space Marines and foul demons in
bolt gun now during last year's skull
showcase I freaked out over the bolt gun
reveal trailer 90 shooters were
initially what got me gaming and I still
very much enjoy deep diving into the
latest Boomer shooter and it's no secret
that I'm an ultramarines Fanboy so it
felt like bolt gun was made specifically
for me which is what I tweeted and was
seen by the folks at orok digital who
then asked if I would lend my voice to
the title
I think one of the reasons this
character appealed to me so much was the
opportunity to get in a booth and just
unleash rage-filled taunts set filthy
Heretics it was almost therapeutic and
it's some of the most fun I've had
recording Vo I think it's rare that you
get to work on something that you were
going to pre-order and play day one and
it's been really hard to bottle up my
anticipation for bolt gun I found myself
even kit bashing and painting my very
own malam kaido just out of pure
excitement and love for this game
now it's time to see kaido in action
bolt gun is available right now on PC
and your favorite console
[Music]
[Applause]
it is time to purge the Heretics
Unleash Your wrath upon the enemies of
the Imperium
plunge headlong into the Grim Dark
Universe of Warhammer forty thousand
who will prevail against the darkness
the ultramarines
[Music]
the emperor
only in death does to the end
[Music]
across many worlds those who threaten
mankind must face a rock
we shall be the end
[Music]
[Applause]
the demon rust stands Fierce and clings
victory in the name of the emperor
[Music]
foreign
School takers I'm here to let you know
about all the many ways the battle
sector has been evolving and improving
since we were last here in front of the
school Throne as I'm sure you're aware
by now we've created battle sector to be
the definitive battle scale turn-based
strategy game for the Warhammer 40 000
universe and in the last year the dev
team at black lab games have been hard
at work expanding and refining Battle
Set first up the deadly Demons of corn
invaded the planetary Supremacy game
mode to add a whole new layer of
Challenge and then they launched a
foreign assault through the Demonic
incursion game mode shout out to karzu
and imperator's pugnus who have
dominated that leaderboard and who
better to count as influx of chaos than
the force of the adapter cerovitus the
sisters of battle arrive is a major
Force to purge all things unclean and
heretical along with the factions we
also added two new battle types in Siege
and season control
as well as four new faction flavored
maps for players to battle on and these
new map types got some serious workouts
in both the live and asynchronous
multiplayer game modes in battle sector
with winter 316 and let's hear Andrew
taking tournament wins and amongst all
this the team also found time to get
steamed at verified release multiple
balance patches and add new community
requested quality of life features we
even rocked up at Warhammer Fest but
that's not all now if you remember last
time I was here I mentioned something
about a right trolling Glam yes boys the
Y is here for battle sector and what's
more it's out now that's 15 brand new
units ozone with joyous DACA and all
looking forward to getting right stuck
in whether you're stomping with the deaf
dreads lobbing DACA with your snazz guns
or just giving the enemy a right good
crumping with your water boss
[Music]
foreign
laughs
give me that
[Music]
the dwarves of character as of had hopes
of reclaiming cousin Crow
only the war parties disappeared Without
a Trace
looks like you will need to save carrack
asgar as all over again I mean Ed I
can't do it alone can't you
oh
hello
and I'm grateful I'll send out some
black powder and you can collapse the
tunnels but we'll do it proper this time
thank you
finish what we started
make the deaths mean something
I know you're suspicious of what I've
chosen but you really shouldn't be
[Music]
advice
and Brook attacks
hi everyone I'm Juan executive producer
on dark type
what you just saw is a sneak peek of the
exciting new content coming to dark type
which we released during skulls
before we talk about that let's have a
look at what we've done over the past
six months
since launch we have worked hard to
improve the game we have delivered two
content drops and nine patches alongside
many hot fixes
some highlights include
content drop the signal where we release
a new Mission and two new weapons
patch 4 blessings of the omnisaya in
which we improve the shrine and its
modification systems
content drop tools of war with feature
an Armory upgrade with 10 additional
weapon marks and new conditions
patch number nine cards and penances
where we revamp the penances and added
new cosmetic Rewards
you're supported with the past six
months have been key in delivering these
updates and we will keep delivering more
content at a steady rate now let's have
a look at content drop rejects unite
which will release during schools
[Music]
all right
two New Missions will be added to the
game the first one archiving secrets we
see your team dispatch to wipe out
sensitive data from The Archives
a session Riser 31 will be part of our
first Community event players we have to
unite to go through three challenges
each granting rewards the final reward
will be Ascension riser 31.
an old friend will also be added to the
game
the chaos flag
alongside this additional content we
will have more quality of life
improvements and Bug fixes added into
the game with patch number 10 a new shop
dedicated to earnable Cosmetics will
open on the Morningstar featuring
additional items to collect
you can now see all ironable cosmetics
in your inventory including those left
to unlock
thank you for playing dark tide until
next time
[Music]
thank you
every shot counts
so little time
but the eye of Terror who shall bring no
mercy
activating the animation
and unseen
bring your life to its end
[Music]
less
thank you
well as you can see there's already
quite a lot for us to get excited about
but there's even more to come next up we
have some exciting updates and
announcements for more Warhammer titles
starting with the highly anticipated
Space Marine 2. now let's join
Lieutenant Titus as he beats Back The
turreted Horde in this exclusive new
glimpse of gameplay footage
what's your status
for coming to you now
they're plotting something
plotting for these insects be capable of
these are mere drones then what guides
them a worthy adversary
you will pay you rotten tomatoes
[Music]
foreign
ation
deltaway report
the spores collapse the bridge there's
no way through get into assault position
by the bridge
hospitality
come forth and be slaughtered
[Music]
We Are The Defenders of mankind against
the Horus the dwell in the Darkness
thank you
well we draw breath we stand while we
stand we fight
we are the Angels of death
we are the blade drawn against the
Endless Night
nothing
survive our Wrath
[Music]
YouTube
foreign
[Applause]
ERS daring explorers who benefit from a
unique style of Freedom normally unheard
of in the Imperium with means to decide
the fate of entire regions of space
little can stop them in their pursuit of
domination and power and they do not
Venture alone their crew contains some
of the Galaxy's most unique denizens
unsanctioned psychos strange xenos
Servants of the Inquisition
and even Space Marines of the adeptus
zestartis or far is a lone space Wolf
Survivor whose pack was defeated by the
murderous drukari
[Music]
of them are ready to follow you on the
battlefield where their unique skills
can be the deciding factor between
Victory and defeat
but the Rogue Traders true might lies in
their personal void ship and the
resource-rich worlds under their control
this is what makes them such dominant
figures
even still the enemies of humanity are
numerous
and they will not relinquish an
opportunity to strike
and worst of all a ghastly Pearl looks
an Insidious corruption which works to
undermine the strength of the imperium's
most staunch Defenders
chaos
only with uncompromising Zeal and
steadfast Faith Can Rogue Traders
withstand the law of the Luminous powers
and those who succumb to the darkness
fit in exchange
[Music]
foreign
all right
[Music]
foreign
thank you
I have fought
[Music]
and Fallen
times Beyond Counting
only to be reforged and you
I feel my Humanity dulled
my memories eroded
my burden way is heavily
in sigma's name
we shall bring order to the Savage realm
for I am stormcast
and my War wages eternal
[Music]
Realms of Ruin is a real-time strategy
game that brings to life age of Sigma
and all of its savagery you'll get to
see games workshops amazing Miniatures
authentically realized in stunning
detail thanks to our wonderful Dev team
and you'll command them on the field of
battle it will be available on
PlayStation 5 Xbox series X and S and PC
today we're revealing our first two
factions for Realms of ruin the Oreck
cruel boys and the stormcast eternals
race of Warriors of Sigmar reforged from
Human souls to fight the forces of chaos
another of our factions is the Sinister
cruel boys foul Lorax Twisted by the
masmal swamp which they come from they
Revel in cunning tricks and traps but
being aurix they also live to destroy
everything and everyone rounds of Ruin
will take you into the wild swamps of
Gir it's this sort of wild called
untamed land where plenty of dangers are
waiting not just the cruel boys
Relentless oric attacks led by the
psychopathic killer boss dank fear
threatened to overrun and overwhelm an
isolated dawnbringer settlement secret
commander of a Detachment of stormcast
eternals left defending the settlement
embark on a perilous mission to obtain a
great magical power that will Aid them
in defeating the oryx and this sets in
motion a Savage battle for survival
which explores the inherent nature of
heroes and villains that draws them
inexorably towards their Fates
progress and succeed in combat you'll
unlock bigger and better units from the
Warhammer age of Sigma Universe what's
really excited me about Realms of Ruin
is that we're dealing with a tactical
strategic combat game but you can view
it how you want to you can pull the
camera all the way out get a really
really good overview of the battlefield
but equally push it all the way in it's
a really visually stunning game I love
looking at all the attention to detail
on the maps on the units on the
animations and the way that even they
idle to how they fight each other it's
just a real pleasure to watch I don't
think anyone's seen anything like this
in a real-time strategy game before
it's been excellent working with Games
Workshop and it's been great for all of
us to actually get time to spend with
the creative people from Games Workshop
and really collaborate to make Realms
have ruin the game that it's become
frontier's Dev team brings a wealth of
artistic and Technical talent but also a
real love for the source material and a
strong desire to do it justice it's
really really exciting for us to finally
announce the game finally be able to
talk about it we've been working on it
for quite some time now and we're really
really glad we can start sharing it with
everyone there's a lot of love for the
universe and there's so much joy that
goes into the development process for
rounds of Ruin it's just really exciting
to finally be able to share that with
everyone you can't not be excited about
bringing these iconic Miniatures to life
there's lots more to be revealed but if
I showed you now I'd be killed I'm not
sure I'll survive the reforging so make
sure you keep an eye on our social
channels for any upcoming announcements
what a showcase that's a lot of
Warhammer to look forward to find out
more about all the games featured in the
Showcase and where to play or pre-order
them by visiting warhammercommunity.com
goals and don't forget to check out
promotions on Warhammer video games
running for the next week there's no
better time to take a digital dive into
the Grim darkness of the far future or
the Savage frontiers of the Mortal
Realms thanks for watching folks
thank you